people generally just want to be left
alone and they want to make their own
decisions hi I'm Nick Gillespie with
reason TV and today we're talking with
Roger Custer he's the head of America's
future foundation f thanks for talking
to us right thanks for having me f is
designed to bring together libertarian
and conservative young professionals
what about that what do you what do you
guys what are you interested in and what
do you do our mission is to identify and
develop young professional leaders for
liberty and what that means is we're the
next step in the movement after students
go to students for liberty or fee or
young America's foundation or is I or
Institute for Humane studies are one of
the 17 immigration army student groups
around and so they graduate they're
starting their careers they're starting
their families and they're still looking
for ideas and solutions especially as
they become taxpayers and fully
functioning citizens independent of the
parents and no longer students so we're
the group that they can come to to and
you've got I mean your base your
headquartered in DC but you've got
chapters all over the country where the
big cities that were you're busting out
and what's your total reach at this
point all right since 2007 we've
expanded beyond DC our largest chapters
are in Chicago Atlanta and Dallas but
we're also in nine other cities and
we're looking for new leaders in
additional cities right to bring these
ideas and reach young professionals with
the ideas of Liberty and you've got what
about 5,000 members around the Krait
around the country talk about what's it
you know I've been to your events but
for people who have them what's what's a
typical event for forev our events are
at bars and restaurants they're
accessible to new people who just want
to learn about these different ideas we
usually have a guest speaker or a panel
discussion sometimes it's even a debate
between conservatives and libertarians
on some of the issues that we where we
have differences what are the issues
that are most important to Millennials
these days as you guys see it I think
the jobs in the economy are the most
important issue because the people are
graduating from college and they're
underemployed or they're unemployed and
it's just a hard to find a job a lot of
them move home with their parents
because under Obama's economy they're
not a whole lot of new jobs and they're
not incentives to create new businesses
especially in new states where there's
all kinds of new regulations let me ask
you this I mean historically
conservatives and libertarians have
gotten along pretty well but there's
always points of friction I know I'm
sometimes called in and after meetings
to be like okay bring in the insane
libertarian point of view and we'll mix
it up but how are conservatives and
libertarians getting along now what are
the big overlaps and then what are kind
of the friction points well I think the
economic areas are where we overlap the
most right and we agree that larger
government unconstitutional spending
unsustainable government programs are
not the solution do and that's where we
have the widest agreement that's where
we focus most of our energies and then
you get to the more social issues where
there's less agreement and I think we
discussed those occasionally wrote but
people generally just want to be left
alone and they won't make their own
decisions whether that means regulation
or a program at the state level as
opposed to the federal level or just
being left alone in general like I
really like Grover Norquist book leave
us alone right where if you want to go
to church all day you want to get the
government out of that if you want to
shoot your guns all day you want to get
the government out of that if you want
to have parties at your house what kind
of parties of them I think you're coming
out in favor of massive pot parties
after church but before the shooting
right right but it's just more up to the
individual veterans and make these
decisions and not Washington are you see
you know as a member of the broadly
defined kind of freedom movement you
know the Liberty movement are you
optimistic I mean because this is the
worst economy you know arguably I mean
it's been a long-standing bad economy
going back to when Bush was still in
office in a lot of ways in your adult
life or your professional life all you
and half people have seen as kind of a
bum economy are you optimistic that
things will turn around or you know and
if so what what's going to be the
trigger point that changes things go i
am optimistic and the reason is because
we've seen tangible changes at the state
level and that's why we've expanded our
pro
was there I mean who would have thought
that Michigan would have passed a
right-to-work reforms in a state that
we're didn't think that was possible no
but I mean it exemplifies kind of a
union workforce in many ways yeah yeah
that in a lot of these states there are
legislators that are enacting policies
that are for economic growth that are
for more freedom voters in different
states have decided that they want more
freedom whether it's in marriage or in
marijuana or in other areas and so I do
see optimism because those changes are
coming from the states you even have
this discussion of having a new
constitutional convention to try to look
at some of these ways that the Tenth
Amendment is being mowed over by the
federal government and so that does give
me optiv is Amal them pretty pessimistic
that the US Congress and the executive
branch are going to make the changes
that will give us a sustainable future
for you well we will leave it there
Thank You Roger we've been talking with
Roger Custer of America's future
foundation f look it up online and check
out their meetings in a city near you
thanks so much right thanks for having
me
you